Episode 2 of "House of the Dragon" revolves
around the Hightowers and their efforts to
convince Princess Rhaenyra that her father,
King Viserys, should remarry. and choose the
teenage Alicent Hightower over the 12-year-old
Laena Velaryon, who's the better candidate
on paper.
Rhaenyra and her father have barely spoken
since her mother and brother's traumatic deaths,
so Alicent takes the princess to the Sept
to pray … but this scene means much more
than you might think.
The Hightowers are the lords of Oldtown, where
they were once the richest and most powerful
family in Westeros.
The Faith of the Seven — the predominant
religion in Westeros — has strong ties there
as well.
The Hightowers support the Faith, while the
Targaryens … not so much.
Publicly, they've converted, but they keep
to their ancient customs and try to limit
the Seven's reach.
By getting Rhaenyra to bend the knee in prayer,
Alicent is flexing her own strength.